there is a dominant form of rhetoric
which I do think it's a theological
which is the idea that I'm I'm a victim
therefore you get to be silent in my
presence because I've described a way in
which I have been victimized by the use
of language but off the beaten path for
him but actually Darren ran into him and
we were doing to change my mind segments
yes out at at SMU is where we were at
that time and he met this professor and
this is a professor of Speech and Debate
I believe over there at SMU and some of
the d-does that I thought was very fast
and we'll talk about this he has people
go out where they have a monument there
on campus and he has them read his
students read the First Amendment at the
very beginning of every semester and
explains to them what it means and make
sure the insures that they understand
what it means so just that alone we said
we have to have this guy in the show
because hey this is treasonous on campus
and be a well-spoken gentleman he is dr.
Ben Voth on Twitter at Benjamin Voth
Voth Voth father said something like I
said bought know you didn't dr. Voss how
are you sir I'm good and asexually both
I should have caught you but yeah it's
great to be here and yeah I love doing
that first time a segment with students
it's important well explain to us what
that is what what it is exactly that you
do so you're a professor of Speech and
Debate correct that's right that's right
I teach communication but I'm the
director of debate at SMU and so debate
is a foundation to my activities on
campus and the First Amendment is really
a cornerstone for that I'd like to have
a first day of class that has high
impact and so students listen to the I
have a dream speech in the classroom and
then we walk out and stand in front of
this First Amendment fetching that's
pretty large on the outside of my
building I'm friendly at SMU and we talk
about the First Amendment and that how
that enables things like that I have a
dream speech but even the speech and
debate activity that we do on campus and
you know I make some pretty passionate
pleas that I can talk to you about in
magog of the First Amendment yeah well
so how do first of how do students
respond to this initially so I would
assume that a lot of them are our
freshmen coming in or it's their first
there
course or maybe it's not but they're
coming in and are learning about this I
will tell you this I never once learned
in depth about the First Amendment in
school I think it's a lot of kids today
I think they react pretty positively I
think there are many different levels I
mean I think there's a number of them
that the category you just described
they didn't realize you know what the
real text of the first amendment is and
then it's standing there right in front
of them while I lecture and I try to
talk about how like the fingers on your
hand there are five freedoms in the
First Amendment so there's for example
freedom of religion there's freedom of
speech there's freedom of press there's
freedom of petition and freedom of
assembly I gotta say if you're gonna
have a free society you need to know
what those are you need to have the
courage of your convictions to act in
those areas and I even make the rather
provocative statement that always gets a
smile out of people
I believe this is what makes America the
greatest country in the world talk about
like Starship America has these five
engines propelling it into this
beautiful future and that usually gets a
little giggle but a little little
happiness out of students who aren't
used to hearing a professor talk that
way do some get upset at the premise
that you think America is the greatest
country in the world you know it's funny
I've done this now for almost ten years
at SMU and I have never had a student
get upset about that and even students
and we do have a lot of international
students and things like that and and
honestly it seems like the international
students are the most likely to come out
to me after class and say I really
appreciate you saying that because
because we don't come up to me and
complain but they usually laugh because
I don't think that's something they hear
from professors very oh right I'm sure
some of them come and say I really liked
what you had to say please don't call
ice what would you consider the state of
free speech on college campus since
that's a big part of you know what what
you direct their first up let me ask
this you said you direct Speech and
Debate you know how would that differ
from say like a professor of rhetoric
sometimes these lines are a little bit
tough to delineate for for students well
to be honest
rhetoric is a passion of mine and it's
like my main training mm-hmm but a
subset of rhetoric is debate training
and so when you engage in dialectics and
even when you're on the campus here
recently you're getting trained in how
to argue and that's a subset of rhetoric
so I actually require my students to
know the definition of rhetoric from
Aristotle which is the Faculty of
observing in any given situation all
available means of persuasion but there
is a set of rhetoric which is debate and
it's a very specialized and advanced
skill but going back to your first
question to be very honest I think that
the situation the first amendment on
college campuses is precarious and
acting in the capacity of debate coach I
travel to a great many colleges and
universities all around this nation and
it's scary yeah I got a note from a
friend last night about the campus I
worked at Miami University in Ohio very
before I came to SMU and they're now
putting up trichter required two
pro-life group to put up trigger labels
for their pro-life display at the campus
that that's absurd and you know I always
say that while we have difficulties at
SMU they're not nearly as to the earth
they are on most other campuses there's
a there's a culture of intimidation and
that's part of why I put in the first
amendment promotion right away when I
got to ask to me in 2008 yeah I was
going to say um why do you think it is
that that SMU has managed to avoid that
to a degree I mean we were there we had
some pretty angry people we had some
some people who who wanted to to rhumble
a little bit we had some people who were
angry at the mere idea of dissent being
expressed but a big reason why we went
to SMU well we've made the the long
travel down there's most schools
wouldn't allow us to even if even a
group would sponsor us most schools just
would say no no it's too provocative
right I'm not surprised to hear that I
traveled to a lot of university campuses
regularly and it's a pretty severe
situation and one where what you
described might be near impossible
I think SMU especially in the past year
has risen to the occasion I'm gonna have
to applaud the students I mean just the
students have risen out for example when
this some of the university thought
about clamping down
on a 911 display and saying it could not
be in the main part of the campus and it
was students who rose up and said no we
don't accept that and students have been
pretty good about diligently fighting
for what really are civil rights
embodied in that First Amendment and
without that I'm sorry to say I think
administrators would succumb to the
larger pressures of political
correctness that dominate across the
nation yeah absolutely you know going
back to one thing that's interesting
because he do mention you talk about
rhetoric can you talk about sort of
Aristotle's definition in the change my
mind segment really isn't debate it
really is sort of more using a Socratic
method just getting people to see if
they've rationalized their own position
if people want to see a debate they can
watch this show or when I actually do
the live show on campus and that's by
design I try to give them as much leeway
as possible but in defining for the
differences like you said rhetoric and
that specific subset that is debate
something that Madison at SMU that the
non-binary prefers they in them pronouns
I see I'm going back to saying she in my
mind but that's an act of violence
that's what I was getting to when
someone like her says man it is an act
of violence against me for you to miss
gender me how would you teach that does
that fall under the wider umbrella of
rhetoric
how does someone how does someone even
rationalize with that that it doesn't
instantly fall under debate I think the
rules have changed and a lot of people
aren't entirely sure how to engage
really in the realm of especially
college policy debate what you just
described and how people I would say
falsely assert hey those words
constitute violence there is a dominant
form of rhetoric which I do you think
it's pathological which is the idea that
I'm a victim therefore you get to be
silent in my presence because I've I've
described a way in which I have been
victimized by the use of language that
those postmodern theories that have
permeate permeated the Academy for a
long time now especially for my own
discipline of communication have created
the situation that you both experienced
and that you're commenting on now and I
don't think it's a healthy thing to say
words are violence and to do and
therefore by a book
should say I require your silence
because you don't agree with me and I
think we need to you know draw that out
and again I come from the park I saw and
I think I saw the whole video last night
I think that's what you're doing and I
think that's what needs to be done well
I appreciate and I appreciate what you
do with the students there I really do
think that a lot of these students have
never actually rationalized their
position I think it's most people in
general I've had people on cable news
who were pundits who were experts Jared
has been there we have these people on
the show when you go home a second
you've never really thought about what
you're saying here good example is in
that video the guy said well you know if
you have a penis for example and like I
have a penis and I said well why would
you assume a penis that's not debate
that's a simple question because he's
asserted this premise which he will then
contradict and if people aren't really
light on their feet if they're not
really skilled in the realm of debate
just those simple questions often not
only trip people up but can create
productive conversation of course not
when people get violent and commit
battery should you've managed to avoid
it do you think as a whole in general
and in the land of higher education
there's hope I mean we see people like
like dr. Jordan Peterson yourself or do
you think it's it's kind of all hope is
all is lost Robert Redford don't watch
that film by the way it is torturous for
three hours but do you see a silver
lining I see hope especially in the
students the students really want a
better more critical thinking pedagogy
and they are being bullied by I think a
small set of what I kind of refer to as
jacobins radicals that want to use
language kind of for their own selfish
ends and you encountered some of that I
think in the campus but it's it is a
serious issue across the nation I tell
state legislators and leaders and
politicians that serious but there there
is hope and there are professors that
are struggling to maintain the open
space and the freedom of speech and
again we need to get back the idea that
like these are civil rights and they are
jeopardized and they're not contingent
upon a category of person that we put
ourselves in we are all as individuals
and certainly as Americans right uh
expectant of these rights well couldn't
we even go
we're talking about the freedom of
speech and that's just a human right not
even necessarily a civil right I know
that's kind of a differentiation that a
lot of people don't necessarily make but
that's an interesting conversation could
we make that declarative statement that
listen the freedom of speech to not be
infringed is a fundamental human
birthright into the Constitution and I
don't think it was an accident that it
was the First Amendment to me it's it
was what they thought first might be
breached by a too strong government but
it is worth knowing and I am somewhat a
specialist on the question of genocide
and I look at I've even been to Rwanda
and trained security forces on the
questions of what we're talking about as
a preventive to genocide and I was in
India this fall kind of similar things
and when you ask people internationally
what they know most about America the
number one thing two people respond with
his freedom of speech and so there is a
sense within all human beings that free
speech ought to be there well I think
the sad reality is it's not there in
many countries I've worked with North
Koreans who've escaped and things like
that it's it's just not there but it
ought to be a human right and I agree
with that
did you enjoy this video here's the
thing your role you're here this is the
end of it so we don't care cuz you
already watched it but if you really
didn't like it and you want to justify
it leave a comment below telling us why
you didn't like the video and if you
liked us let us know and subscribe to
the channel because that lets the
overlords at YouTube know that you know
what you're alright